all right uh the white house now pushing
back against criticism over president
biden's
absence from weekly coronavirus phone
calls with governors all across the
country
the intention was never for the weekly
call the covet call that is led by our
covid coordinator
to be a part uh to for the president to
be leading that call
uh that the intention was for our covet
coordinator to be providing an
update directly from the president i can
assure you that uh the the american
public
governors hear quite a deal quite a
great deal from the president
on his plans to get the pandemic under
control
but despite what she says some state
leaders including our next guest say
that's not really enough
and are calling to hear directly from
the commander-in-chief
nebraska governor pete ricketts joins us
right now from omaha hey
governor good morning to you good
morning thanks for having me on
great to have you so i think vice
president kamala harris has been on the
phone call
once during the administration joe biden
never has been
when the call was uh being made the
covet called during the trump
administration
how often was mike pence or the
president on the line
so in the last administration there were
40 weekly calls
about the pandemic mike pence chaired 39
of those which means he was on the
entire time
answering questions from governors
fielding those questions sometimes these
would last a couple hours long
and president trump joined us for eight
of those phone calls
which is in stark contrast to this
administration where the calls last
about 45 minutes
and vice president harris has been on
once for about five minutes she didn't
take any questions right
it really shows the difference in
approach of the white house
right now and how they really don't
appreciate
the work the governors are doing right
now in the states where we're on the
front lines
and really shows a lack of leadership on
the part of the white house well and i
know you feel that
this is not the bipartisan approach to
the covet call that the administration
the incoming administration
had promised you but ultimately
are you getting the same kind of
information in this call which
i believe is being kicked off every week
by the the president of the national
governors association
governor andrew cuomo yeah governor
cuomo kicks it off and we hear from the
white house staff and we certainly
appreciate the fact that they're
continuing to do the phone calls
and we appreciate the white house staff
that are giving us updates but there's a
big difference between getting
the updates from the administration and
having the top people on the phone who
can cut through the red tape and the
bureaucracy
hear directly what's going on in the
different parts of the country right
i do this regularly with superintendents
mayors counties health directors
municipal fishers so i get a feel for
what's going on across my state
and that's part of how i help cut
through the red tape and make decisions
sure and that's not happening with this
white house
well and in fact i think it was just
last week
you were i think driving around omaha in
your car
you were listening to the radio and
there's there's a news flash about
colvin
that they should have told you about
wasn't there
yeah the whole decision to pause j i
heard about on the radio
and i guess the white house i guess
that's how they found out about it too
because apparently they didn't know
about it and again this just shows that
this administration is not doing a good
job of communicating even internally
with themselves
if the cdc is making this announcement
not telling the white house or governors
if we're all caught by surprise and
it really needs to get fixed sure and
because i know during the trump
administration
the president had said because every
state is different
you know obviously nebraska different
than new york the
the state governors would be essentially
in charge of executing
the covet strategy but this way
the way it's going right now it's get
less control
right i mean they're just telling you
okay this is what you're doing
well and i give an example that you know
these
these emergencies are locally executed
state managed and federally supported
and one of the things that we've been
talking about is trying to get smaller
vile doses from the administration and
they are going to bigger vital doses
just one example that i think if the
president or vice president would hear
directly from governors
could hear that you know what is needed
in new york is not necessarily needed in
nebraska and vice versa
they have a better feel for how to
really make sure we are customizing this
response
to the entire country rather than just
maybe one part of the country or right
right one i spin all answer all right
well let's see after
you know you guys have uh raised this
concern let's see if the vice president
and or the president start picking up
the phone call
at 11 o'clock every tuesday morning
governor ricketts thank you very much
for joining us live today from omaha
great thank you very much for having me
on